we are live
zubin and you are wearing a tremendous
soccer
proper football jersey um hello
everybody welcome to coffee and commerce
i'm gary vaynerchuk with my partner
in crime here zubin lobby
uh he is dressed up for halloween i'm
impressed
and uh and i'm we're sorry we're a
little late it's on me
um i have a client uh emergency which i
was just in
i'm gonna jam here for a couple seconds
i know we have a bunch of guests
i'll try to stay for one or two but i'm
going back into that meeting
so i'm going to let my handsome partner
here take the lead jubin how was uh
how's vaynercommerce's uh week been
vaynercommerce's week has been
incredible uh
yeah it's just uh lots of momentum
brewing
and uh yeah really excited about the
clients we're working with prospects we
have on the horizon team we're building
all good stuff love it by the way so
somebody in the comments just say i'm
dressed as garyvee i've already gotten
10 different dms of people that are
dressing up as me
uh for halloween tomorrow which i think
is i i told my mom i've made it
all right let's get right into i know we
have a bunch of guests lined up let's
just get right into it
you're right gary hi stephen how are you
my friend
how are you i'm all right thank you um
yeah so the first question is tiktok and
shopify partnership
what are your thoughts on that question
yeah so look gary's been talking about
tick tock for a long time about
attention consumer attention where
people are
and naturally where people are is where
advertisers are going to go
and so tick tock's uh advertising model
is somewhat nascent right now they're
just starting out
but at the same time you see uh social
media increasing social media usage
increasing e-comm increasing
so it's a natural fit right it's the
same way that facebook is integrating
with shopify
instagram so on and so forth so they
want to integrate ecommerce
and i think it's just the beginning
right now it's going to basically allow
folks that are on shopify
to be able to produce content for tick
tock eventually it's going to allow for
native
um transactions within tiktok probably
but it's just natural right all you see
the writing on the wall is very clear
it's been for the last
five years frictionless commerce so
allow people to buy where they are where
they see product and so i think it's a
natural fit it'll continue
yeah you know jordan i think from my
standpoint it's two very progressive
fast companies doing fast [ __ ] with each
other
and it's and it's just a good idea for
both companies i think
i think in a lot of ways amazon's the
biggest e-commerce company in the world
but if you think about it amazon
in a lot of ways has microsoft dna where
it's a closed system it's amazon
what shopify is taking a approach of is
an open web
kind of like an open source environment
almost right
you can just see it right you can see
the microsoft versus apple or the
microsoft versus google like
the closed versus the open the publisher
versus the you know wordpress like
shopify has clearly taken on
that scaled approach and deals like this
lead
you know lead to the inevitable headline
that will happen which is shopify is the
biggest e-commerce
company in america because no matter how
big amazon
is if shopify is the close second and
has everybody else's business
that will surpass if you're just like
you know
fast dimes beat slow quarters you know
and so
i think it's a very strategic uh
announcement and don't forget in big boy
land and big girl land
an announcement like this sometimes is
strategic for shopify and tick tock
because it may lead to other big tech
companies reaching out to them and
saying
hey so you did this hey hey we're
spotify tick tock why don't we do this
podcast deal together
hey hey hey shopify we're twitter we
want to do what you did with tick tock
so there's a lot of macro strategy
in announcements like this makes sense
yeah i think
just to add one thing to gary what gary
mentioned right now that i think is huge
is the fact that if you look at the
other announcements that happen with
facebook and instagram and shopify
those were to shopify's benefit it
almost like increased shopify's level of
credibility
but what this is doing is this is
allowing shopify folks to access tiktok
and by virtue tick tock is getting a lot
of clout in the business world
for partnering with shopify so it's
about that yeah credibility
yeah very interesting thank you awesome
great to have you on
talk to you soon mate
sorry i'm actually actively posting my
next instagram post as we speak
i expect all of you to like it as soon
as you can
hello hello hi
hi everyone hi gary yeah please be
careful while you're driving the ship
freaks me the [ __ ] out esther
no don't i'm really good i could go 60
miles in vietnam
i don't want to see your eyes i like
what you're doing keep focus on the road
don't even look at us i'm not fire away
okay fine so
my question is coming from an industry
that's traditionally not
a e-commerce high-end audio it's uh
something that
that you have to come and listen to just
like buying i guess like a rolls-royce
right most people
are not buying it without driving it um
what are some tips you guys could give
uh to myself and i guess people in the
industry
um for for this covered time where
you know people are less reluctant to
come to an event or go to a dealer
i know i know a lot about esther's
business like super high-end
audio equipment like completely crushes
when people come in
what's your perspective on that
high-touch experiential
brands figuring out the
e-commerce ecosystem you know i think a
lot of it is analogous sales
so not necessarily like there's only so
much you can do right you can basically
play music through someone's speakers
when they're on your site but the
reality is
it's dependent on their speakers so one
of the things you can do is basically
show what it sounds like
if they don't have it by lowering the
bit rate and whatnot or a lot what a lot
of brands do i think what's interesting
if you listen to it on
radio for example when they talk about
color uh
they use audio or for example in this
case when you're talking about audio
to show visuals so something analogous
they can explain to that consumer
because the reality is
unless you feel it unless you hear it
you've got to drive that emotion in
another manner
okay yeah so you you can't fight reality
and if your equipment
is in a situation where it is so much
better
experienced one of the things to think
about with e-comm
is for example one thing i think it's in
that's interesting is
the idea of
converting all your traffic on your
website to live streams
like appointment not transactional the
whole
experience is this is so unbelievable in
real life
that the closest we can do to this is
schedule your 15-minute appointment
to do a zoom or a google hangout or a
stream yard
because we feel like you'll get a better
sense in this environment so it's
changing the game and innovating
okay yeah and together final thought
esther like to gary's point
what are the biggest missed
opportunities that's happening right now
in terms of omni-channel and retail and
digital
is enhancing the digital experience to
leverage your retail staff
so allowing people to be able to
basically uh schedule a 15-minute chat
video chat or audio whatever it is with
someone in store who can actually guide
them
okay so you're saying like engage them
because i i hear what both of you are
saying i just feel like
you know with something like this it's
like it's it's um
like experiential it's something you
cannot really translate into a zoom
because
really especially the audio files and
i'm trying to go into the lifestyle
market
stick with me here on this if it's not
transferable
on the internet yeah then the answer is
you can't do anything
right which is a [ __ ] [ __ ] answer
always
right so to me to me i apologize zuma
i'm not
i'm i'm in the zone here brother and i'm
about to leave anyway but esther
to me
if you tell some like to me if i'm
buying
high-end sound equipment and i'm too
scared to go to berg
to living center bergen right over to
the store
i still think i appreciate the white
glove nature of you
trying to show it to me right and so
you're not selling me on the sound
because call of spade a spade esther
most [ __ ] don't understand the sound
anyway you know it
and i know it it's no different than
wine
what what they appreciate is your effort
to give a [ __ ]
right do you understand yeah the amount
of people that have the ear
to understand the [ __ ] slight
variable ear difference of the [ __ ]
like most people don't have it's the
same as palette the reason i built one
of the biggest wine companies in the
world was
all the nerd [ __ ] that everybody focused
on with wine i realized that nobody
could taste it anyway
so i needed to talk to people more
realistic the reality is
i don't give a [ __ ] if every person in
the chat right now came to your store
and heard it
and you're like see the difference
they're all gonna say yes but they don't
know what the [ __ ] they're talking about
i hear it's true i know it's true i know
which is why i think the white glove
effort
makes me say wow this lady gives a [ __ ]
about me look at the conversation i
asked her a question
i showed her well do you think with that
tv she's like nah
and now all of a sudden you brought
[ __ ] value and you're winning on the
block you see where i'm going i love it
right now i love it i don't want anyone
else in high end audio to hear that
esther
last you can't be greedy with my free
content
here's the key number two esther is that
what i love
love about life is the first time i
delivered you the idea
you're like yeah but they're not gonna
hear it right notice how when you it's
life perspective you can look at
everything negative you can look at
everything positive
by me reframing the perspective of the
actual thing that's going on in that
environment with a consumer
now you go to i love it i love you for
seeing it that's [ __ ] business right
there that's communication
vantage point thank you guys so so much
have a great weekend shabbat justin can
you come in here by you too
dust get in here yep i need that clip
chop that's a huge linkedin that's huge
instagram like that moment right there
i'm going to watch i'm going to read the
i'm trying to read the comments right
now
that was a [ __ ] big deal zooming did
you see that
oh absolutely people are people what i
was telling you earlier
it's about the framing it's the framing
it's the framing and your ability to get
them from wherever their mindset is
into your frame and then they'll get it
yes you've been talking about a big
meeting we just had and i understand the
context yeah you initiated like three
four different ways you see it resonated
at some point
and you leaned in on that and you went
in it's brilliant
thank you g thank you sir all right
let's keep it moving
let's do it gary zubin how are you
good for your absolutely
uh so basically uh i'm the managing
director co-founder of graystone premium
organic teas we're a family-run business
for the last
four years um we've been super lucky
we've basically last year did about 600k
um we're on target to go probably close
to a million this year that's the gravy
the bad part we have a barely functional
website almost
no social media to speak of so when the
pandemic
starts coming you've come to the right
place
bro i've been following you for at least
two years
four days but chef you
you were following but you didn't
execute enough on the core thing because
you had other ways to sell
and when disruption came it becomes a
pickle right
100 100 it was always that we were
behind always trying to get to this like
we got lucky we got on shelves we were
selling
but we've missed tons of opportunity
along the way mainly because we are
a small family-run business me my dad my
brother probably get it i totally get it
but the problem is just like i was
yelling at my best friend and not
yelling just everybody knows that's my
slang term
just as like i was on zoom earlier with
brandon today brandon wernicke my best
friend since 14. i worked with him for
20 years
runs wine library when i hear you talk
i'm like
literally this guy's been like drilled
into his head
25 years 30 years of me 20 years
of me as a business partner and i said
to him
if you do not fix the well
you will always lose and when you keep
focusing on sinks
you're gonna lose two years ago when
this became obvious to you i'm like
social
dot com you're selling a product you
gentlemen pro i understand why
focused on the things in front of you to
make 600 000
but boom unfortunately shitty
because it's extreme because it would
have happened anyway but kovitz sped up
the process
of the inevitable and so most like i
would have wished that you went did 412
last year
but had your [ __ ] fundamentals right
but that's what every [ __ ] buzz
yes you have every [ __ ] business does
this they focus on that
but when you it's one thing if you don't
know it's one thing if you don't even
know
it's another thing when you know you
need to do the right thing but you're
still
so [ __ ] pumped about the thing in
front of you 600
[ __ ] 600 412 to do 1.3
you know what i mean agreed 100 i mean
to be honest with you
had we from day one marketed to our
clients properly
had inserts followed them up targeted
them retargeted them
got those repeat sales from them we
would already be over a million
my thing now is is that good news for
you
is that it's not going to slow down
right that what's happened
is there's been disruption in the market
that's gotten you to go oh [ __ ] now i
need to do something about it
but the good news is not going to slow
down don't curse because zachary
greenville johnson
who i love because i see him in my
community all the time i said garyvee
you're awesome but you need to work on
your potty mouth
less cursing will greatly broaden your
audience so
being i just want to make sure that you
know i want you to be able to broaden
your audience i just need to stop you
there
please my audience is very small so we
need to brag
but but but the reality is you've got
time right not to say you shouldn't do
it
get those fundamentals right but go
ahead you were going to ask a question
well they died
i apologize ship hey dustin it's oh luwa
spamming the crap out of facebook we
banned that person in perpetuity i got
you
thank you yeah the question really was
this is that
we're building out the website but as
i'm doing that i'm listening to gary
tell
speak on uh voice text
you know zubin bringing up shopify plus
uh you know there's so many avenues like
to me
the website's nice but i think text is
where it's going next and probably voice
after that
and it's just
but don't worry about drones you don't
even have a website right
that's like worrying about sex before
you kiss someone
fair enough thank you in the next
dustin dustin that's also a good one i
think that's a millie on [ __ ] the
gram okay
i got you absolutely chop it up baby i
love it
listen just real quick tactically
speaking right some of these things that
we talk about
text voice ar vr all this stuff
you require a certain level of scale
before you can actually leverage it
right
how are you going to text people and
leverage it when you have five people on
your text list
or leverage email if you've got 100
people on your email list
the key is start with that foundation
build your
real quick hold on hold on this is so
funny to me elise elise i'm sorry i'm
reading the comments
elise peterson says no t business is
doing a million dollars a year online
there's i know a four i don't even i i
know
four off the top of my head well i
i guarantee you that if we had executed
properly we would be doing a million
online
i i i'm gonna i'm gonna show some right
now while you're talking go ahead uh
go ahead yeah so anyway what i'm just
getting at is like get
your foundation ready and then look at
all these other avenues
i think the problem is though you're
concerned right now because you didn't
you didn't jump on the yeah
up upton t aggio the t
spot t2t all doing well over that
just on the record adagio
am i right brother am i right though
the problem is you feel like you missed
the boat on your site so now you don't
want to miss the boat on text and audio
and vr and all this stuff
you haven't missed the boat just get
your foundation ready
and when the time is right and when i'm
talking about the time is right it's not
the macro time it's the time is right
for your business
then you implement text and you do a
voice and you do all this other stuff
get yourself agreed gary question for
you what would you do
to build an organic brand's
community what would be the first three
steps i would put out i would do t
t library tv what i did for wine i would
do on t
i would have a daily show about tea
tasting it breaking it down
having guests come on i would search the
entire internet all of social
to figure out who the tea lovers are
that are influencers invite them on
virtually
send them a happy package that you have
behind you to them so you both can
do tea together then you do the tea
together then you chop up the pieces of
content then you make them instagram ads
i mean i mean there's a lot of things i
would do it's why i build big businesses
like
content and and modern social media
marketing at scale
agreed would you also look at facebook
communities for that type of thing
i i think that's a nice to have i think
i would start with doing a tea
tasting show every single day building
up my personal brand
getting influencers involved filming
like this note
i'm giving you advice i live i just told
dustin to clip two things from this
you're gonna be in one of them you're
gonna be talking a bunch in the video
and then i'm gonna say
kiss sex you know like that's what like
you know so like like
i live every piece of advice i give i
live that's why i love
being who i am in the world it's free
and i live it
most people charge for things they never
lived literally the people that try to
look like me on the internet
charge for ebooks and programs when
they've never actually built a business
outside of charging people
for ebooks and programs i give it away
for free and live it i'm giving you the
advice that i lived
100 and i truly appreciate it as they do
all your i mean to be honest
spend 57 000 hours finding influencers
that like tea and send them packages
invite them on the show
drink tea with them talk about tea with
them make some jokes make some
talk about the world events then then
put that on youtube
that will get 400 views but then you're
gonna take three clips from the best
part
and you're gonna put them on your
instagram you're gonna run a hundred
dollar ads against them
reach out with your site i'll be happy
to give you advice as well just reach
out
i 100 will thank you so much luke and i
truly appreciate it
shiv where do you live montreal canada i
love it one of my favorite cities in the
world i just gave a keynote yesterday to
c2
c2 i know i saw it man i couldn't
believe you read i was like how
i i missed this i know a couple of guys
over at c2 i would have tried to wrangle
my way around it
well it was all virtual but i can't wait
to come physical but um
nonetheless um there's so much to be
done in that environment anyway
thank you ship thank you both guys
appreciate it truly
see you man this sucks i uh completely
missed my fire the show's almost over in
three minutes
i just want to say one thing dustin get
ready winetext.com
can people leave me a comment about this
i'm really curious because we're doing
zumian and i are doing more and more
thinking and strategy around sms
how many people right now in the
comments can you lead um
with uh leave a comment did you are you
signed up for wine text
in the comments yes no
or about to because if you buy wine i
want you to see how this process works
um just curious where everyone sits yes
you're signed up no you're not signed up
because either you signed up and you
unsubscribed or you don't know about it
or
you can't because you're in tech you're
in texas or chicago or outside the u.s
or um or uh about to
you're doing it right now because you
actually love me
and you want to do nice for my dad um
because
now don't sign up if you don't drink
wine because that doesn't do me anything
because it actually costs money some
text
it is the most frictionless shopping
experience you'll probably have
not yet nice thank you marina a bunch of
nose no texas makes sense about to thank
you jamie
see some nice yeses all right um zumeen
you want to sneak one in by yourself
i'm gonna say goodbye now thank you for
the show dustin get me those clips asap
i may do split screens i might just let
it play dustin on the second one let him
talk a bunch up front
and then i just come in with the punch
line instead of like how we do it
normally
awesome cool and dustin i'll go ahead
and stay and just get everyone through
it's all good
cool
go ahead zubin i'm just reading the
comments real quick it's all good go
ahead let's get the next person in
drew hey how you doing what's up
all right so i have an eco-friendly
all-natural skincare company
in the past we started with soaps and
lip balms and stuff that could be
marketed to pretty much
everyone so our market is very broad so
far literally everyone
so you know uh we've recently launched
beard oil
so my question is what are your thoughts
on targeting specific groups of people
that your product isn't directly made
for in my case
i'm thinking of targeting uh gamers and
streamers
with the beard oil because that's just
booming right now what are your general
thoughts on
so i love this question i'll tell you
why i love this question um
i think this applies to so many
different organizations right now
specifically around the pandemic so let
me give you an example
this is obviously an issue not an issue
it's a topic that
all sorts of brands deal with hey this
is our core audience this is who we
target
now i want to go after this audience
should we do it so on and so forth
right what the pandemic did is it
actually got a lot of businesses to
shift significantly
and target brands that they would have
never or
individuals they would have never even
sold to before like they were in
performance gear and now they're making
masks so they're doing this and doing
that right
right right now here's the interesting
part
a lot of these brands got a lot of
revenue doing that right but
what ended up happening is they
alienated their own market
or or that revenue was so much more than
their core revenue
that then what happens is anybody
they're looking at if you're looking to
sell your business you're looking at
raise funds whatever
they're going to apply some sort of
covid discount to you because they're
going to say look you would have never
even had these people and once the
pandemic's gone
are they still gonna be your customer
right so the
i think the thing that's really
important with your question is to
understand at a macro level where are
you heading
and will those individuals is this a
sustainable play
right right in your case i think it's
sustainable play
you're jumping and catching on to
something somewhat early
and able to that that market's only
going to grow right
it's not like they're only gaming right
now because of the pandemic
right right or the or it's like they're
only going to do it a period of time so
i think it's a fantastic
idea now the other thing i'll say is i
think something that's
uh super under leverage is personalized
creative
and personalized creative in terms of
marketing as well as like on site
so if you have the ability to i would
create landing pages environments
experiences specific
to the gamers and streamers so that they
like land on your site
or or they learn from an influencer or
through advertising whatever
they get to your site and there's a
landing page dedicated to them so they
feel like your product is for them
that makes sense how do you feel about
i've seen companies like
like gum companies that are like gum for
gamers it always to me it seems gimmicky
when people say
this is just for gamers when it they
really they haven't changed the
ingredients or anything what are your
thoughts on companies doing stuff like
that
let me tell you what gary would say
which i would say as well but
he would tell you to be authentic right
and
look people resonate with authenticity
and genuine uh content
so what i would say to that is get a few
gamers
get a few people that actually know that
market
to promote your brand so that it's not
like you're it's not like me
who i'm i started playing fifa by the
way so i'm not a gamer but
i love fifa anyway um it's not like me
promoting your product where they're
like what the [ __ ] is this guy
his beard doesn't look good and he's not
a gamer you want something that's
actually like legit
right you're reaching out to those
influencers and there's so many people
right now
that are gaming on twitch all over the
place and so get that core audience
just be real basically just be real and
authentic
the gum brand i'm sure will do well if
it's real
but people see through [ __ ] and uh
endorsements as well yeah
that's how it was for me i mean the
first time i saw it was like come on
yeah yeah exactly are you a gamer
yourself i am and that's kind of what i
was drawn to perfect
perfect then yeah absolutely do it okay
all right well i appreciate awesome
good to see you thanks absolutely
likewise see you
all righty who do we got next we got
rhett
almond how's you been super stoked to be
here
great to have you yeah i'm super excited
here so
what i wanted to ask was i've kind of
got this influencer omni channel i'm
launching that's focused on like social
media management
e-commerce talent management and things
like that
and right now you know the services i'm
providing are digital services
i'm sure you've seen like reese's came
out with the
digital meets physical campaign um
so so did hulu because you know they
kind of were
looking like they did the hulu drive-in
and
uh even recently burger king just
launched something with
the the creepy clown that was physical
meets digital
so i was wondering what kind of physical
experiences could i use to
activate a digital campaign or a digital
service company yeah
i love this question as well so were you
listing when gary was talking about the
white glove
uh treatment for high-end audio products
and things of that nature
yeah so i think let's expand on that
because again as i was mentioning
earlier as well
there's this whole um notion if you will
last few years that retail is stale
retail needs to be more digital
all this stuff right integrated and it's
not to say it isn't true
but i think what we often forget is that
digital could become more real
and the connectivity between the two
isn't necessarily
it doesn't have to be predominantly on
the the physical side it's how do we
leverage the physical within the digital
world and i think a couple ways to
answer your question
um in terms of like the the ways you
mentioned what hulu did
uh perhaps what rhesus did the challenge
with those sorts of things that they're
one-off
and they're very very specific um kind
of
opportunities to engage with the
consumer in the real world that don't
apply to most brands
but what does apply to most brands that
are in retail
is they've got retail staff and they've
got a website but what they don't have
is the ability to leverage their retail
staff to help upsell on the site
so you'll you'll see that they have like
chat boxes that pop up and all this
stuff but it's not real
like imagine you go to um a site
and you start to um
shop and you're adding things to cart or
you're viewing them and all of a sudden
something pops up and goes hey you can
have a free consult
with someone in the store right now
right and you can actually chat with
them right there
they can talk to you like let's assume
it's a makeup line or
it's something that uh a stylist or an
advisor would help
i mean even when you think about
high-end audio products again um
the consultative sale is what's missing
online
right and the ability to be able to
speak to somebody connect with them
i think that's a mass opportunity and
frankly the reality is
most of those implementations right now
are one-off so if you're talking about
like hey what do i do for my business
and how do i build a business around
that i think there's a business right
there
love it so inside of a similar vein
a lot of my current digital efforts are
very top funnel
how would like for an influencer
marketing agency where you know it's a
client service based business
how would i then drive them down further
to a
conversion point uh using either the
digital or the physical model you just
mentioned
mention the first part again i didn't
hear the first part so
right now i'm doing a lot of stuff with
online marketing and
it's very top funnel and it's
because of that it's kind of making it
tough to drive people down
to like a point where they're actually
ready to what are you selling
first it's a client service based
business so
influencer marketing got it okay so a
couple things about client-based
services because obviously we're in
client services and have done this a
long time in terms of like
generating marketing qualified leads
sales qualified leads all that stuff
increase the barrier of entry i know it
sounds counterintuitive we talk about
sales online we talk about lowering the
barrier of entry
i firmly believe that in b2b sales you
should increase the barrier of entry
what do i mean by that
don't make a [ __ ] form like hey
let's work together and what's your name
and company
and tell us about yourself like there's
zero barrier of entry you're gonna get a
shitload of people that aren't actually
serious
what i would do is increase that barrier
of entry understand what sorts of
questions when you're selling to
somebody what questions they ask
qualify them before they even fill out
the form
i love that that's that's amazing
awesome they jumped that up for me
awesome man it was great that was great
awesome keep in touch man we'll do
see you
all right we've got carl wyatt what is
going on
how you doing nice beard fantastic
yeah i turned it up just for you guys i
appreciate that
all right so my question uh i was hoping
that gary v would be able to kind of
i was going at this right here i'm going
to connect you with gary after because i
i selected this question for gary by the
way oh awesome i appreciate it
yeah why don't you go ahead and ask a
question i'll chime in but honestly i
want to connect you with gary for this
yeah so
the question is is how does someone uh
get in on the game you know like
especially with covet a pandemic that's
going on there's a lot of foster kids
out right now um
i'm very passionate about it i'm an
ex-foster kid myself i grew up in the
system
from the age of three aged out so i know
the struggle
and uh just try i was hoping he could
give some advice not exactly like a road
map
but just like words of confidence or
advice of how to get in
yeah and when you grow up in the foster
care system a lot of kids uh get that
hustle mentality
so how they could capitalize on that
into
uh starting their own business online or
or
retail store totally um
look i think that
i think that one of the biggest
challenges people have
is not growing up in an environment
that gives them confidence now whether
that's
um whether that's in in foster care at
home
in a different environment etc and i
think the the problem that a lot of us
have in the world is is that lack of
confidence and that lack of confidence
when it's not instilled in you at a
young age
is challenging and it requires a lot
more self-motivation
and really understanding um
understanding that everybody is capable
of anything they really put their mind
to within reason
and the fact that i think what's
interesting with the world now versus
say five years ago 10 years ago
is the stigma around a lot of jobs and
careers that people have
is disappearing the world is changing
and i think people are
less so than before
judged on what they do
and more so on their character and
integrity yeah
and i think that it's important to be
able to provide
those that you mention in foster care
with that opportunity
and with the ability to speak with
people connect with people
like yourself that have been there that
are successful now
that are confident as well as other
people they can just give them a
different way of
thinking and realize that whatever they
want to do
and i know it's kind of cliche to say
lean into your passion but we live in a
world right now specifically in the us
where literally whatever you're
passionate about you can make a shitload
of money doing
yep and i agree yeah
again this is this is i really wanted
gary to take the song because i know
that he'd provide a lot of
more words of inspiration and wisdom
than i can on this subject
um and i'll definitely connect you with
him oh yeah it definitely sounds good i
do have i did
i was hoping to get on i did get him
this right here i don't know how much
tea he could fit on there but
i got him a little yeah it's coffee cup
when i was card shopping the other day
no but yeah uh that was the whole reason
uh my wife and i we recently moved out
to utah
and i'm i'm in the step back moment what
garyvee talks about
um so i got a couple businesses i
started out here i
i started a window professional window
cleaning business for commercial
residential
i also started a new youtube channel for
foster it's called fostering skills
to teach kids uh just any little
hands-on skills
uh whether it's home improvement or just
words of advice and
giving them information about the
resources out there available to them
absolutely and i think carl what's great
about the community and you can see in
the some of the chats
like people are recommending different
things hillary d i mentions use the
garyvee search engine
yeah it's awesome and helps me every day
i think those things are great
um look we're all one big community we
need to help each other we need to
support one another and if we don't do
that then what's the point of
anything else we do yeah yeah we got to
lift each other up and
yeah we have to totally agree absolutely
okay sounds good i appreciate the time
thanks for coming on thank you
that's everybody that's everybody um
thank you so much everybody for tuning
in really enjoyed this episode i hope
you like these sorts of
episodes we'll be interviewing we've got
a ton of guests lined up for the next
few weeks but
please let us know how much you like
these episodes and if you like and we'll
make it more frequent more regular
hope you enjoyed this uh session our
um objective with all this is to make
sure that you're getting value out of it
so please let us know
what topics you like what you'd like us
to lean in more on what you'd like us to
talk less about
just want to make sure you're getting
value end to end appreciate your time
have a wonderful weekend and see you
soon